all right welcome to my round five recap
from Vegas I just finished about 15
minutes ago so yeah no time to shave or
eat the recap must come first uh in this
one I was playing against Noah Ward who
is a pretty young player uh maybe 13 or
14 years old but has gained a lot of
rating recently
and I decided to play Pawn C4 on move
one so repeating the English opening
that I played a couple rounds ago
and he played the move C6 which I was
expecting I found a few of his games in
the database I also found his chess.com
account so I was uh just sifting through
all his opening lines before the game
and I saw that he's a slav player so if
I play D4 or start with D4 on move one
he played D5 and um this is one of his
main openings as black so one of the
reasons I played C4 is that after he
plays C6 I don't have to go into a slav
I can go into what's called a panov
baffinic Carol Khan and this is one of
the benefits of playing the English
opening is there certain lines for black
that black can't quite achieve because
of the English move order so
um so yeah black can't transpose into a
slav and he goes for D5 I take take and
this is a line that I played in
or that I play it I played in Reykjavik
except in Reykjavik I took here and then
played D4 I think and my opponent made
the mistake of taking too early I should
have played Knight F6 but the lines are
very similar because very often white
will end up with an isolate Queen's Pawn
which is what happens right away in this
game uh now eventually black will win
back the pawn and my opponent played the
most accurate move at F6 uh doesn't make
sense to take right away and allow
Knight C3 with Tempo so this is still
Theory I play Knight C3 he takes and I
play Knight to F3 and it does look a
little bit strange to delay Pawn D4 but
uh I was actually following a Carlson
smaits game from years ago Carlson won
like a really nice game over GM smates
where he delayed D4
um and I think that game went Knight C6
Bishop B5 E6 Castle Bishop E7 and then
D4
um something like this but uh
one of the points is white completes
development first and then only later
plays Pawn D4
so going back our game followed a
slightly different route
um now Knight C6 and Bishop B5 did
happen but instead of playing E6 which
is the most common move uh my opponent
played G6 which I was only slightly
prepared for like I knew the next few
moves as white but I didn't look at this
line super closely during the game I
believe my opponent only had one or two
games on his chess.com account from this
position and I think one of the games
went Knight C7
um he may have had a game with E6 as
well but G6 was a small surprise now I
have encountered this move maybe online
and once in a tournament like years ago
and I was uh prepared with Queen A4
which is the main line pressuring the
knights on C6 and Knight is pinned and
it's a little bit awkward for black
because Bishop D7 would obstruct the
queen from defending the knights and
just blunder in Knights so it's not that
easy for black to actually deal with the
threat of Bishop takes C6 and it turns
out the main line here is Knight B6 to
sacrifice a pawn and after takes takes
takes Bishop D7 Queen E4 uh I would have
been okay entering this position I think
the engine gives a small Edge for white
with extra Pawn but black definitely has
compensation with the bishop pair and a
pretty open position and black can play
against the ice like Queen's Pawn
so uh our game didn't go that route
because instead of Knight B6 my opponent
played Queen to D6
and he played this move relatively
quickly and at this point I'm completely
out of prep this is a new position for
me and I didn't know if this is like a
theoretical move or maybe my opponent
just got careless and thought maybe it's
only moved to defend but I do have the
the database open this has been played
about a dozen times in Master Level play
so we're still in some Theory but during
the game I thought this move is very
questionable for black because it gives
white an opportunity to seize initiative
right away and I played the move 94 and
now the queen is attacked and it's tied
down to defending of the knights and
black is essentially forced to play
Queen E6 here and I thought it's already
a great success uh chasing the queen to
a square where it blocks epon and the
lights for it Bishop but I realize it's
not so simple to get much of a clear
Edge because uh first of all the knights
pinned and I really want to play Knight
D4 but that would obstruct my queen from
defending my knight and allow Queen
takes E4 so for that reason I play Pawn
D3 first uh just a flexible move
defending the Knight and now I'm
threatening to play Knight D4 to the
queen and the Knight and just um yeah if
Black's not careful it would be a
winning position uh so here my opponent
took a long time
um we can see he's played pretty quickly
in the opening only using a few minutes
but he took
uh over 20 minutes to play his next move
Pawn A6 and it's an interesting move
because he's not actually threatening to
take the bishop due to the pin but he is
preventing my threat of Knight D4
because if I play Knight D4 then he can
take and in the end after takes takes uh
box doing very well getting two pieces
for their Rook so in some sense A6 was a
prophylactic move like preventing Knight
D4 because it doesn't work tactically
but it's also a useful move because
there's many cases where I will have to
address the fact that Mac Bishop is
attacked by the pawn and uh now my queen
is tied down depending upon to The Rook
so again I took a lot of time here um
because I do have options I can Castle
um I can hit the queen with Knight G5
and ultimately I decided to attack the
queen with my G5
um and it's forced to move back to D7 uh
so it looks a little bit awkward still
because uh there's a lot of pins in the
position the pawn is pinned and the
Knight is pinned and originally when I
played Knight G5 I wanted to play Knight
C5 in this position
but then I realized that I'm just
chasing the queen
to a more useful Square it's no longer
in the way of the pieces and it seems
like white has good initiative but I
couldn't quite make this work like I
wanted to play Queen D4 attacking the
Knight and the Rook
um but I think there's some problems
like Knight F6
and or maybe even Queen A5 check first
I'm not sure about this line
um maybe there's some other options for
black as well so after a long think I
decided to Castle and I burned a lot of
time on the last few moves I'm down
about 10 minutes on the clock
and then here my opponent took a long
think
and ended up playing a move which I
think was a key mistake
um now during my opponent's time I was
trying to calculate and the move I was
most scared of which he didn't play was
just Bishop G7 and I didn't really see
what to do after this like I wanted to
play this but then he has Queen D6
hitting the knights and I didn't see any
way to keep an edge like Knight E4 Queen
C7 and it just seems like my initiative
is fizzling out and blocks ready to
Castle
and if I have to take them I can see the
bishop here on top of that I have the
isolate d-pawn so
um I was thankful that my opponent
didn't play Bishop G7 but rather played
the move Knight to B6
and at first this move actually looks
fine for black because it's an attempt
to just relieve all the pressure and and
essentially Force matters because now my
queen is attacked and there's some
interesting lines like originally I
wanted to play Queen B3
uh and essentially sacrificed the bishop
and take on F7 and if we were to enter
this line I don't know what's going on
and I spent a bit of time trying to make
sense of this position but I didn't end
up going for this because I just saw a
much more clear and strong option I
ended up going for Bishop takes C6
and at first this move doesn't seem to
achieve much because we do trade Queens
Knight takes A4 was played take on D7
take on D7 and we get to a position
where it looks like black has survived
the worst of the storm like Queens are
traded I no longer have any pressure on
the queen side and black has a bishop
pair and better Pawn structure
but uh what my opponent had overlooked
was the fact that I have a temporary
Advantage due to more activity and I can
make use of my more active pieces in a
really interesting Manner and when I
played my next move my opponents I think
immediately realized that he's in
trouble so if you haven't seen the game
and want to pause the video and find a
very strong move for whites feel free to
do so
and it's interesting because this
position it doesn't seem like black
should be in much danger but the move is
Rook to E1
and the powerful thing about this move
is I'm threatening Knight D6 check and
Knight F6 check
and it's really not easy for black to
prevent both of these these threats but
if you give Lock an extra move to play
Bishop G7 and Castle then black should
be doing fine but there's really no time
to escape the the trouble and my
opponent took I think about 20 minutes
to play the next move and I was actually
surprised with the next move because he
castled queenside just walking into a
fork I was more expecting Bishop E6
which at least
tries to cut the the losses as much as
possible for black now of course white
is doing well here uh I can take and
then play against the double e pawns and
white is definitely for choice but after
casting Queen side it was just another
gift and I think it just kind of
downward spiraled for my opponent after
it takes
um he did try and fight and get counter
Play Bishop G7 but then I keep the
pressure and actually in this moment I
reached out my hand about to take the
Rook on h8 and then I pulled back
realizing that I couldn't just leave the
Rooks Fort and decide later which Rook
to take
um so I thought for a little bit more
and played the move Bishop G5 so now the
pawn and both Rooks are attacked and
here my opponent has nothing better than
to capture the B2 Pawn uh he played
Bishop takes B2 I was actually expecting
Knight takes B2 but I think at this
point it doesn't make too much of a
difference
um light is uh is doing very well
regardless
and after Rook a B1 he plays Bishop E6
which is an attempt to muddy the waters
hitting Knight and the pawn and here I'm
just trying to to simplify the position
so I take the Rook he takes on E2 and
then I take on V2 because I saw the line
after ticks Rook C1 Kim B8 I skewer the
knights and the bishop and uh yeah black
really doesn't have any time to take the
knights on h8
um because then I take on B2 and I'm up
a clean piece this would be winning so
he tried to get counter play he took on
D3 uh saying oh no my knight of course I
didn't take the Knight because trackmate
is a threat
um but here I have a really nice just um
consolidating move Knight D2 which
blocks a rook and essentially prevents
black from defending the knights so now
I'm guaranteed to win the Knight or the
bishop and after Rook dates I take the
knights hitting the bishop he plays
Bishop D5 and then it looks like my
knight is trapped but I can save it with
the maneuver Bishop F4 check King A7 I
play Bishop E3 check King 8 and then
Bishop D4 and now I'm up two minor
pieces two knights for that matter for
two pawns and at this point it was just
about uh cleaning up and making sure I
didn't make any terrible mistake uh so
now we'll just zoom through and see how
light converts this position
a lot of it was just making gradual
improvements making sure the pawns don't
get too dangerous
and at some point
um I give a check I give another check I
win the pawn
and then finally this Knight has had
enough of being in the corner
and I played Knight F7 and very quickly
we're gonna see the minor pieces
coordinates after B5 Knight D6 A3 Rook
B3
um yeah black is now essentially losing
one of the pawns because of A2 I can
check and win the pawn so he plays B4
and after Rook takes B4 A2
uh at this point I am just looking for
mating ideas and the resulting mating
that is actually really beautiful I
start with Rook B6
um so idea being that I want to check
and win the pawn and after he plays
Bishop E6 then there's a really cool
Force mate uh Rook A6 King V8 Knight dc8
King B7 and white to move Checkmate in
one
Rook A7 and actually at the end of the
game there's a small kid watching uh
watching the final moves play out and he
was uh he was like laughing out loud uh
because of the the eventual mates and I
felt a little bit bad because usually
Spectators should not
um be chuckling at a game in progress
but it was a cool kind of um mating idea
that you don't see too often like a king
on B7 but the minor pieces coordinate
really well because my knight defends
the other Knight which defends a rook
The Rook uh checks the king the bishop
plays a role and these squares are also
controlled so nice finish so what I
think was a pretty smooth game
um maybe it could have been more of a
fight I think the key moment in this
game if we go back to this position uh
yeah Knight B6 I think was just a big
error and I think it resulted from the
fact that my opponents did not calculate
I'll move further in this position
because if you saw rookie one from a
distance maybe he would go for Bishop G7
instead which I think was a better
option
so uh I think that does it for this
recap I am three out of five I'm not
sure when this video will be uploaded
but friendly reminder to check out my
twitch channel for all the morning games
uh Jonathan trance is doing commentary
um he's commentated two games so far
both of which I lost so hopefully in the
next one I can uh I can bring a victory
but I think the goal for now is to get
food and get sleep so thanks for
watching I do appreciate all the
positive comments
um and uh and all the yeah all the
people watching especially those who
watch until the end of the video
so stay tuned for more and I'll see you
guys soon